okay we'll hear back on overtime welcome
back nice to have you here on the panel
okay this is for uh Caitlin
what I don't think anybody has put
[ __ ] in the chip bag in the same
sentence so this is a career high okay
and that's why okay Carry On all right
get me back in a reversal New York City
announced they will tighten in missions
to their top high schools and rely more
on Merit rather than the lottery system
that was previously used what do you
make of this well merit's obviously such
a country traversal word right now what
is it meant but what's meant by Merit is
it what you did on a test and why is one
person able to you know have access to
so much testing material Etc but I'll
tell you those top schools
um that that have traditionally you know
Stuyvesant and and Bronx Science those
kids who test out high and you know who
went to wrong size is aoc's father and
built their life that way yeah went to
where the Bronx High School of Science
oh it's one of those test in schools so
she wasn't horribly disadvantaged well
I'm not saying that I'm just saying that
those schools take have just
traditionally taken test takers which is
a controversial thing to say but those
kids tend to really push forward and do
very well so it's tough
for him
um look I uh I think we have a big
bigger problem which is China
which is educating and graduating as
many Engineers every year as we graduate
all college students and so we're facing
a economic educational superpower and
don't know what to do with all these
kids in our country we can't afford to
keep wasting genius the merit-based
system seemed to leave out a lot of
people some this Lottery stuff doesn't
work out as well as people want to
choose we've got a big problem and so if
somebody wants to try to try something
different what's going to happen is it's
going to turn into a big kind of woke
War about stuff that at the end of the
day the kids who most need the most help
are still not getting it so you know I'm
not going to pass judgment on this
particular proposal but I just think
that the one thing we should be coming
together on is the fact that we want our
kids to be able to compete on in a
brutal global economy with China and we
are way off track right now wow but
we're kicking each other's
for kicking China's ass with kids who
have degrees in the dramatic and visual
arts so I just want to say
they may have all the engineers but like
it's not like we've and communication
skills are off the charts okay so this
is for you should the U.S continue
working with Iran on a nuclear deal not
at all
no no not even that look because at the
same time one President Biden Jake
Sullivan who I just met uh saying that
our thoughts and prayers are with the
people of Iran but at the same time when
they continue negotiating with these uh
murderers it means that they're giving
billions of dollars to those who they
condemn well I mean I don't get this
contradiction because um well because
it's about nuclear because we don't want
Iran to have a bomb because there are
obviously you have to make difficult
choices sometimes especially in
negotiation no this is the easiest
choice because look when you keep
continuing with the merriers instead of
actually putting pressure on them that's
not going to work the Islamic Republic
only understand one language language of
pressure why because they're killing now
Iranians in the streets they're taking
hostages look right now British citizen
Swedish citizen German citizen U.S
citizens are in prison Iran using them
like bargaining chip to get a deal
imagine a day that the US government ask
its own allies just downgrade your
relation until the day when you release
all the political prisoners then we're
going to negotiate with this
here
okay well I I want to imagine a day when
that isn't the regime in Iran and and
one way to get that to happen where that
isn't the regime in Iran is to work with
them because right now
um as long as we keep these sanctions on
we're the bad guy that's one way that
regime stays in power because they can
blame their problems on the big bad
Satan in the west who's forcing them uh
into these horrible restrictions
economically can I tell you something
they always blame you but whatever you
do they always blame you but let me be
clear while
the U.S were sanctioning the Iran uh
like the Islamic Republic at the same
time when we were suffering from
sanctions the money went to Bashar Assad
the money went to Hassan
at the same time 51 religious
institutions their budget got increased
do you know what it what is their job to
kill Masa to promote Sharia laws I
remember that uh Javad zarif and its own
love is going to different media CNN New
York Times saying that oh my God the
blame is killing people because we don't
have medicine but Java zarif came on TV
and said proudly we built a hospital
in Venezuela so they sent the money to
everywhere the money doesn't go to the
people of Iran that is why I'm trying to
say that of course we are suffering from
sanction but the blame should go on the
people who are actually fueling the war
in the region the children of the
hostage takers are here in America can
you believe that
spoke person of those students who took
American diplomats hostage now her son
lives in America and she is welcomed on
CNN like analyzing the news of Iran come
on guys she's the hostage taker okay
agree to disagree
all right uh as Putin annexes four
regions of Ukraine protests are erupting
within Russia and thousands of men are
fleeing to evade conscription do you
think these are sizable setbacks for
Putin well yeah uh I mean yes yeah I
mean those are our viewers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well maybe they just want to get us to
have a discussion about what's going on
in Russia and uh yeah maybe another
question on this would be where does
this wind up in six months I mean it
seems like Putin is already backtracking
on conscription because it was to say
the least unpopular but he couldn't get
the he couldn't get the people to sign
up to begin with I mean for the
beginning of the war people in Russia
they were already evading the draft I
think it's it's really extraordinary
what Ukraine has been able to accomplish
[Music]
um
yeah Russia has not Russia has not done
a mass conscription since World War II
Russia didn't do conscription for
Afghanistan as much as they got their
butts kicked in Afghanistan they didn't
do it then so it gives you a sense of
the resolve the Ukrainian people the
effectiveness of the of NATO and other
allies and the fact that that uh Putin
has really stepped on a rake uh he does
not know what to do no and um so now
he's you know having you know bizarre he
saw the press conference today bizarre
sort of you know a birthday party for uh
his newly conscripted uh newly uh uh
territory
um but my view about it is that we're in
very dangerous territory now because uh
this is unprecedented for a nuclear
power to be attacking a country and
losing the way that that Putin is losing
and losing face the way he's losing
faith and I don't see the off ramp yet
uh so you know right now I think we're
happy but you know uh worst days are to
come I agree
uh should federal dollars be spent
rebuilding areas affected by hurricanes
especially as climate change worsens the
effects of these natural disasters
well I mean we first got to know you
because you were the climate czar
uh look I I think we're gonna look first
of all look at the insurance industry
taking a big step back now not wanting
to flood insurance anywhere in the world
that's a leading I can't get fire out
here yeah very I mean yeah no that they
will not insure you yeah so it's just
too risky there's just I mean talk about
effects of climate change if you don't
think it's real yeah that never happened
before it just that's something for you
at any price
and then it's with it's it's flooding in
Florida it's the same and same thing so
and so I think that when the private
sector says hey this is not a good idea
and we're not going to back it I don't
think the public secretary should then
show throw bad money after good I mean
that's a tough thing to say but the
reality is we keep rebuilding and we
keep getting washed out we keep building
we keep getting washed out those dollars
could be put to work in other ways we
are going to have to because we didn't
do the right thing uh 15 years ago when
you and I met on climate policy we're
going to have to wind up retreating from
some of these coastal areas that's just
the reality and it's not just United
States around the world we need to get
ready for that right glad I never moved
to Malibu thank you very much everybody
[Applause]